lawang how are things with you new
roommate
you know it's great as long as she keeps
a mouth shut I have to ride around in
this cesspool of your mind all day and
not talk about it I wish I had skin so I
could stroll out of it you pull this
oversexed idiot she agrees now much
doubt that please Peter with respect and
kindness lawang she is very dear to me
oh look someone with manners shocking I
am sure you two will find a way to put
aside your differences in the name of
the greater good if by greater good you
mean me getting my money then I heartily
agree money is an illusion
used to hypnotize small minds but it's
your helps when you're trying to buy a
bottle of good whiskey I need four
themes first a demonic rod then the skin
of a large mammal and some raw cheek
wrestles they can usually be found near
black brain pools careful though the
pools are what seems to be causing the
mutations and the animals out there
maybe I'll pick up some dinner while I'm
at it I would not recommend eating them
I'm doomed I will also need golden
chrysanthemum Wow
crystals and flowers hey dudes we're
going to harmonize our resonances and
use them to levitate the Pentagon
something like that come on the sooner I
had these materials the sooner I can get
chemical back where she belongs all
right all right back in a jiff
boomstick
mess with the bull you get away
you know what's funny just for the holes
goes the boomstick
but not the ugliest thing I've killed
today
you
Wow look at you Mama's little deep talk
whoa
bang bang bang [ __ ]
you
throw away I didn't expect you back so
soon
funny how efficient you can be when
there's someone in your head yelling at
you all the time do you have a problem
with efficiency
so you and chemical are getting along
then I wouldn't call it getting along so
much as getting through enough chatting
let's get on with it
the rock doesn't choose the river nor
the river the rock yet neither would
exist without the other
tell him to lay off the cryptic wisdom
and make my stupid potion already Kimiko
says you're full of [ __ ] Oh doc tells
very much okay she said to lay off the
cryptic wisdom and make the stupid
potion already that's my girl my items
please here you go
oh and hey Kimiko had a question or was
that fingered a goner it is a spirit
well an extremely powerful artifact say
what now it is like a container olya can
hold a person soul wait seriously why
can't I live in there instead of with
this idiot she wants to know why you
didn't put her in there it would not be
a good idea once you have entered a
spirit well you will never emerge oh so
it's like a comic-con this is a complex
operation it's going to take me some
time check back
you